she won't hug me ever okay she hates me
deep trauma wild raging fires and a
heartbreaking situation we nearly had a
significantly more emotional story in
enganto we are covering the darker
alternate endings that almost made it to
the screen bruno makes bad things happen
number one time to get the tissues
okay so we did still lose pedro in the
film but at one time there was a
possibility that it was so much worse
abuela alma's love was going to pass
away at the river at the same time that
alma was giving birth to the triplets
talk about devastating at least in our
version pedro got to meet and say
goodbye to his children and to be there
to support alma
number two and then there was alma
knowing pedro wouldn't have been able to
meet his triplets is heartbreaking
enough but poor alma would have faced an
even more intense and tragic experience
being pulled between the joy of having
her children and the heartbreak of
losing the love of her life and her
co-parent loss is never easy but these
moments happening at the same time could
have made alma's relationship with her
children much more difficult
number three you never know what you'll
find when you go to a place you used to
call home at one point in the
development of the movie mirabelle was
seen running away from the city meaning
abuela had to go back to the place she'd
run away from to find her when back in
town she'd stumble upon a mural
dedicated to her love pedro with this
quote to love it all is to love entirely
and if that weren't emotional enough as
it is abuela alma was going to stay by
the mural side all night long eventually
after finding mirabelle we discovered
the truth as abuela shared what had kept
her walls up after i lost him i was so
afraid
i couldn't bear the thought of losing
anyone else
number four so many apologies so little
time
understanding why abuela was hurting so
much led to a different apology that
involved her explaining that her
deep-rooted fear of the miracle actually
made her forget who the miracle was for
abuela also carried the blame for
pedro's death feeling that it was
because she left the city that she lost
him and while it would have explained
why she was so scared of losing anyone
else this heartbreaking turn would have
wrecked us
number five fights between family
members can get pretty vicious
while it was abuela and mirabelle that
faced tough conflict together an
alternate ending saw mirabel and her
mother julieta having a brutal and
heartbreaking argument one that would
upset mirabelle so much that casita
would fall to ruins as a result of it
number six
this house is on fire yikes flames
nearly took down the casa madrigal and
what was left was meant to be a deeply
haunting image there was an alternate
end that saw casita burn to the ground
an especially painful turn of events
considering the candle was what kept it
going for so long after the tragic
burning a haunting scene would have
taken the place of the beloved madrigal
home only doors and windows left
floating among the ashes with an
especially dark and kind of threatening
looking spear left in the rubble which
was meant to be the remaining cracks of
the house going this dark would have
made for a very different feeling than
what we got
number seven
someone call the doctor
possibilities for how cassita could
suffer were extremely varied and one
alternate storyline for cassita saw it
showing signs of illness physically
storyboards that didn't make the cut
show the paintings and photos hung up on
the walls of cassita going blank a sign
that the home was experiencing a kind of
brain fog at one point even the yellow
butterflies went dark seeing such a
major loss and darkness in the house
would have made the concern for
cassita's deterioration way more intense
in the end we hate to see cassita
hurting
[Music]
you got this
just gonna save the miracle
number eight there's a new patriarch in
town and his name is agustin
in another version of the film augustine
was the one who decided to build the
madrigal home even after being warned
specifically not to this man was very
different from the one we got to know to
paint a bit of a picture
he had a mustache at the age of four
knowing that it's not too surprising
that even after a mysterious woman gave
him an intense warning not to build the
house he opted to go against her advice
this certainly doesn't sound like the
agustin we know and love and we would
have gotten quite a different movie if
this had been the reality
number nine you never know what you'll
find in a river if you thought casita
was magical this river is next level an
alternate story line saw mirabelle
nichole find her abuela how did she do
it by following the magical river which
would have in actuality ben abuela's
hair the journey mirabelle took would
have seen her exploring more of alma's
origin story and journeying through her
past uncovering all the trauma and
heartache she'd had this detail and
seeing just how long and deep that river
was would have brought a much more
intense vibe to the film highlighting
the true depth of abuela sorrow in this
case
this river
is where we were
given our miracle number 10 it would
have been an ugly sight
sisters can fight there's no doubt about
it but one version of encanto saw a
pretty intense scrap between isabella
and mirabelle that's right we almost saw
these two totally duking it out but it
just didn't feel right to see that kind
of violence in their relationship so the
team decided to scrap it who would have
guessed the fights that we got were the
toned down versions
the only thing you have ever done for me
is
nothing is messed up
number 11 there were other options
and they were shockingly different from
the oso suave mariano isabella had her
eyes on a different character one we
never got to meet named bubo marquez
this suitor was meant to be a man from
the city with a modern and unique style
to those in the village meaning he stood
out quite a bit oh and in terms of
personality this guy was meant to be
quite the goofy dork which no doubt
would have made for some fun moments
number 12. chispy the capybara almost
wound up stealing the scene while many
alternate story lines in encanto made
for a much darker ending there was one
post-credit scene that was cut that
ended on a much funnier and perkier note
the beloved chispy the capybara wound up
being drenched by casita an adorable and
hilarious scene that luckily did wind up
being released later on who knew there
were so many directions to go in when it
came to the story of the madrigals while
all the options would have brought
something special to the film we're big
fans of how the team decided to tell the
story would you have liked to see any of
these other story points included